foreign
what's going on Lindsay
Hi how are you we're doing good how are
you
I'm great thank you for asking you're
welcome
how can I help today
so um a brief rundown about what's going
on is that I
sold my shares and partnership in my
business sold my house and came to
Columbia with my husband so we could
live here in his hometown and start a
life here and we went to buy some land
to build our Dream House on
and we found out the day that we was
closing on our land that
his mother had actually stolen his
inheritance account and we was unable to
purchase the land and this has just put
a string of financial hardships on us
since we found this out how did she
steal how did she do that if his
if his name was on the the inherited
account
um he did allow her access for the
account just so she could put money into
the account when he needed her to do so
for his errands to help that but um is
she in jail
no why I wish why didn't you call the
police somebody sold more than a quarter
of a million dollars from you and your
husband
that is very true but he is very
forgiving and I'm forgiving too but I
also have a responsibility to make sure
me and my wife eat
that is very true but and we're not
talking about chump change we're talking
about
three hundred thousand dollars that's
what my screen says she cashed in her
mom card when she decided to steal from
her son and his wife
correct and now we are at the point
where
um we can't pay our property taxes and
we're having to move back to Kentucky
and thankfully
the business I was partnered in and had
cheers in is allowing me to reinstate
all that and I can start work again soon
but that's all great what you're saying
I'm sorry to cut you off what you're
saying is great I'm glad that things are
kind of going on the up and up with your
job and that there's some great things
happening but that's not the solution
to what's taking place with your
mother-in-law and I don't want you to
think that you're having to move back
because you didn't prosecute the person
who stole the money from you and seek uh
getting re repaid
I I agree but um
now things they're just really hard and
we're having to sell all of our property
here in South Carolina no no no no hold
on you got to change your language
because you are choosing to not hold the
person accountable who stole from you
you are thus choosing to sell everything
leave that state and go start life
somewhere else
no nobody's forcing you to do anything
you were making all of these choices
correct
okay so what what question do you have
for us
um I'm having a hard time with my
husband
um yeah I would be too
he's very forgiving and even though no
he's a coward yeah I don't think that's
forgiving I don't think that I'm gonna
call that
attribute forgiveness he's a coward I I
would forgive too
but but even though she's done all this
and we've continued seeing her
still try to steal from us to this day
we he wants to continue financially and
support her after we move yeah but
you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that that's what
I try to convince him but it seems to be
wants to because he's you know an only
child and she's realized right all right
we gotta we gotta
I'm not in the business of telling
people to
that their marriage is over that well
that's not true I've told people that
but I was gonna say you have told people
that John I'm not in the business of
telling people they need to get divorced
I want you to I but I am in the business
of telling the truth here's the deal
behavior is a language
what your husband is telling you loud
and clear using no words at all
that he will force his wife to go to
work so that he can provide
um food and shelter for someone who
stole everything from his family
he would rather keep a thief
um
he would rather keep a thief having
living standards above that of his wife
and I take a much broader view I've said
this on the show before I take a much
broader view of of fidelity we're
obsessed with marital Fidelity when it
comes to sexuality but we we've
completely throw it out when it comes to
financial Fidelity emotional Fidelity to
psychological safety we just get rid of
all that so when it comes to cheating on
your husband is cheating on you with his
mom not in a sexual gross way but in a
whose needs come first way
and until you stop using language like
well we're having to do this or how and
you step back and say I am worth more
than this
and I'm married hit you you told him
um all mine is yours and all yours is
mine till death do us part and he told
you that too and he's going back on on
what he said
and until you choose to decide that
you're worth more than what you're doing
you're just gonna end up back in
Kentucky working full-time doing your
thing and sending part of your paycheck
to your husband I mean part of your
paycheck to your mother-in-law who stole
from you
Lindsay have you guys ever done any kind
of counseling
any any marriage counseling
no we haven't but this is our only issue
that we've had um
no it's not it can't be
um if you were to say to your husband
hey
this is a this is an issue for me and
this goes just beyond our conversations
we need we need to speak to a
professional what would he say
well he would be very open to it he okay
does everything he can to make me happy
then let's do it not ever hold on not
everything
uh when it comes to
uh yeah besides that but but when it
comes to his mom that means food
clothing shelter living in the same
state jobs future
besides those few things he makes sure
you're happy
what is what does that mean that he gets
a burger before he comes home like what
does that even mean that he keeps you
happy
here Jade's right Jade's right I I'm
getting frustrated at him and I'm taking
it out on you and that's shame on me so
I'm gonna be quiet now Jade is Right
you've got to sit down with a marriage
counselor one that will do the right
thing and take sides in the therapy
session and let you you are so convinced
that you're in the wrong and that you're
crazy and you just need to say just the
right thing and then he'll come around
he's not coming around he's picked mom
over you and you are going to have some
hard choices to make moving forward and
you need to get a professional in your
choir John is telling you the truth I am
too we just want the best for you
Lindsay we're not trying to gang up on
you we're simply trying to tell you the
truth and change your situation for the
better this is the Ramsay show